[music]
>> Alhamdulillah.
Was salat was salam al Rasul Allah wa
ala alihi wa sahbihi ajmain.
Amma bad.
A'uzubillahiminashaitanirrajim.
Bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim. Wa man
ahsanu qawlam mimman da'a ilal Allahi wa
amila salihaw wa qala innani minal
muslimin. Rabbishrahli sadri wa yassirli
amri wahlul uqdatan min lisani yufqahu
qawli.
My dear participants, I welcome all of
you with the Islamic greetings,
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Inshallah, for the next 45 minutes
or as time permits us,
I'll be speaking
on the subject which we missed
and we could not complete yesterday
on introduction
to the Dawah training program.
And after that, inshallah,
we'll continue
with
the
techniques of giving references.
And then have a break or if time
permits, we'll have the revision of the
25 surahs names and meanings. If time
doesn't permit, we'll have it after the
Maghrib salah and then after that we'll
have revision of the Quranic verses,
inshallah.
Because tomorrow is
a holiday,
not a resting holiday,
a training holiday, more homework and
revision.
Inshallah, we can afford to extend today
without causing loss tomorrow,
inshallah. How did this
training program come to my mind?
As many of you may be aware,
that I was inspired
to become a da'ee
by none other
than late Sheikh Ahmed Deedat,
rahimahullah.
And when I met him the first time in
1987, he was passing from Bombay and
hardly had a stay of a day.
And my brother and I said that we'll
hold a talk of yours. He said, "In less
than 24 hours, how can you arrange?" We
met him late in the night and said,
"Tomorrow evening you'll have it." He
said, "Impossible. Without publicity." I
said,
"At least give it a try."
And alhamdulillah, [clears throat] he
agreed.
And in less than 24 hours,
without any publicity of giving ads,
etc., which we could not, only on phone
calls, masha Allah, we could gather more
than 1,000 people. At that time, that
was also creme de la creme of Bombay
in one of the auditoriums.
And Sheikh Deedat was impressed that in
less than 24 hours without publicity,
1,000 people coming.
And alhamdulillah, he agreed to come
again on an official
trip.
That was unofficially he was going to
the village Takkeshwar.
So he came back in 19
and we organized
a tour
in which, masha Allah,
he gave about 18 lectures.
>> [snorts]
>> He was for a week in Bombay, went for a
couple of days
to Bangalore. And during this time,
he also gave a pamphlet that
he's having international Dawah training
program for two months
in the year
1988.
He said, "Though the list is finalized,
we have selected I don't remember the
exact number what he said,
about 20 or 25 participants he has
selected, everything paid for, etc." And
that time was just the beginning.
We did not know anything about Dawah,
met Sheikh Deedat, and inspired by him,
but that was the beginning. And I was in
the medical college.
And he said, "Though the list is
finalized, if you want you can come."
And it was just
at the time the medical college exams
and all of them.
I said, "Maybe inshallah Allah will give
another time." And that time it was just
the beginning, as I said. We were
inspired by Sheikh Deedat, but didn't
think of becoming a da'ee. As time went
on
and being inspired by Sheikh Ahmed
Deedat,
I saw most of his
videos.
Not only from the official lot, even
from the unofficial lot. Unofficial lot
means officially he had a series of 1 to
it was 60, then went to 70, went to 80.
Then he had an unofficial lot which I
had a habit of collecting all video
tapes of speakers. So we had a
collection of, masha Allah,
about more than 300 videos of Sheikh
Deedat. The official had 60 at that
time.
No, less than 60, it was 50, then kept
on increasing.
In 1980s, it was less.
And so most of his tapes,
some once, some twice, some thrice, some
four times, some five times.
And
he was my mentor
through the video.
Met him a few times, but through the
video. And we started repeating.
And when I started speaking about Islam
in the medical college,
majority non-Muslims, hardly
3 4%
were Muslims. When I spoke about Islam,
most of them ran away thinking, "Now
we'll be
beaten. We'll be attacked now. So let's
not stay with Zakir. He's doing Dawah.
We'll get a hammering."
So most of the Muslims when they used to
hear me speaking about Islam or doing
Dawah
to my non-Muslim friends
in the medical college, they used to run
away thinking that he will get us
hammered. But alhamdulillah, if Allah is
with you, none can overcome you. If
Allah forsakes you, then no one can help
you.
So that's how my Dawah started and I
started speaking very softly with all
the
knowledge I got from Deedat. I started
speaking softly and humbly. And
I got no results.
I said, "What is this? Same matter of
Deedat I'm speaking. Why I'm not getting
results?"
Then I thought, "Okay, let's
be like Deedat."
And I remember in 1988 when Sheikh
Deedat came again for the second time in
Bombay,
I was a chauffeur, I was a driver.
That time I was about
23 years old.
Less than 23, 22 years old.
And I asked him, "Uncle,
why are you so aggressive on the stage?"
And you could have put me down saying,
"You shut up."
But he said, "Son,
there are two ways of fighting the
devil.
One is with holy water,
the other is with fire. I chose the
fire."
He replied to me calmly
that one way is to fight the devil with
holy water, the other is with fire. I
chose the fire.
I'm not aggressive, I'm militant.
He said, "I'm coming from the Pathan
race and I'm a I'm a mujahid." And that
was the answer he gave. So when I
realized that I'm not getting results, I
changed my style.
And there was a time I was more
aggressive or more militant than Sheikh
Deedat also.
So if you see some of my old recordings,
we don't want to circulate now,
you could see me with the fiery
Zakir Naik,
thin, few hair here.
And then alhamdulillah, as time passed
with experience,
I remember
we started the organization, Islamic
Research Foundation, in 1991.
Mainly to give a platform for da'ees.
Then I was a stammerer.
Those who know about my background,
if you ask me what was my name, I'd say,
"My name is Za- Za- Za- Za- Zakir." That
was it.
So in my dream, a person in his dream
can dream anything.
That is what psychologists tell us. In a
dream you can dream anything. You can
dream things which are not possible. But
I, because I was a stammerer, in my
dream I could have dreamt of becoming
the best doctor in the world, the best
heart specialist in the world. But never
ever could I have dreamt of speaking
even in front of 25 people.
So the passion
increased and I told my parents, I was
about to pass my medical studies, but I
decided that I should spend more time
for Dawah. That is in the
90s.
In 1990, just before passing my
third MBBS.
And after passing your third year MBBS,
I passed 1991, there is internship.
Internship means you have to serve in a
government hospital for one year. At
that time we are more relaxed.
So that time we started the Islamic
Research Foundation and I told my
parents
that because I wanted to do my post
graduation, I told my parents I want to
do Dawah at least two hours a week.
Because when you do your post
graduation, you have to stay in the
hospital 24 hours. Maybe once a week you
can come for
half a day, one day, depending which
hospital you are or what's your posting.
So I said, "When I come home, that time
I'll do two hours Dawah." So we started
the organization, Islamic Research
Foundation, thinking I'll give two hours
a week.
Parents said, "No problem." Then as
when we started the foundation, I
requested two hours is too less.
I planned of doing
surgery.
Then I said, "Surgery?
I hardly get half a day in a week.
In that two hours you have to change.
So let's do radiology." Radiology means
you can come home every day, you don't
have to stay overnight. So, maybe I can
give more time for Dawah.
Then I told my parents, "How do you give
2 hours every day?" They said, "No
problem." So, all my plans of post
graduation changed from surgery to
radiology.
While doing internship, we started the
foundation, Samruddhi Foundation.
And then I realized that 2 hours a day
is too less.
Then I told my parents
that I think I should give
half time for Dawah.
And my father happens to be a doctor, a
psychiatrist. My elder brother happens
to be a doctor.
So, we are a family of doctors. We have
a business that is very lucrative,
alhamdulillah.
And it was the desire of my mother
that I should be a heart specialist.
Somewhat like
Dr. Chris Barnard. And if you're aware,
Dr. Chris Barnard
his full name is Dr. Christiaan Barnard.
He hails from South Africa, the same
country as Sheikh Deedat.
And he was the first
surgeon who did the first heart
transplantation in human being.
And at that time it was new.
So, my mother said, "I want you, son, to
become like Dr. Chris Barnard."
So, when I asked her, "Okay, now I'll do
50% Dawah, 50%
medicine."
And I asked her, "Now, would you like me
to become like Dr. Chris Barnard
or like Sheikh Ahmed Deedat?" So, my
mother
being intelligent, she said, "I want you
to become both."
So, I said, "As Allah wills."
>> [music]
[music]
[chanting]
>> Allah.